[Music]
this video is sponsored by
me since i put a lot of time and effort
into it so
also if you're in any way invested in
this channel stick around until the very
end where i have a couple of updates
regarding my schedule
as well as the upcoming one-year
anniversary of the channel next week
[Music]
ever since ocarina of time all 3d zelda
games and some 2d installments as well
gave link various means to make
traveling around
faster and less troublesome be it on
horseback ships
a train or a rideable bird companion all
served to aid him on his quest to rid
the world of evil
and breath of the wild was no different
aside from the paraglider which was
already an amazing addition
we once again had the option to ride
various animals catch our own steeds
name them and use their speed to our
advantage and in a world as vast as this
one
they were definitely a welcome inclusion
but you know what you can't do
on a horse
oh yeah after purchasing the second dlc
pack the champion's ballot and
overcoming its challenges
link is rewarded with no less than a god
damn motorcycle
or as i like to call it the horse
redundancy cycle zero which
totally eradicates the need for a horse
altogether i mean why should you
can't do this on a horse or this or this
those bastards won't even budge when
faced with more than a 30 degree incline
the master cycle 0 says nay to that and
lucky for link it runs on basically
anything
rocks fruits and plants chicken legs
goat butter
freaking fairies but i gotta hit the
brakes real quick
as cool as the master cycle zero is this
isn't what we're here to talk about well
not entirely anyway
instead what i want to focus on today is
that which leads to this awesome reward
that being the final trial link has to
overcome before facing off against monk
moss kosha and receiving this
technological wonder
there's quite a bit of mystery and
confusion surrounding this place
why is it here and what purpose does it
serve why does its interior have so many
similarities to the divine beasts
pair that with the unusual reward at the
end and you got yourself a subject ripe
for some good old theorizing
so let's talk about the so-called fifth
divine beast found in breath of the wild
hidden away in a cave located on a ridge
atop the great plateau we find the
shrine of resurrection
the very first place we see after
booting up the game it is here that link
opens his eyes after having been in
stasis for 100 years and
is set on his quest to face calamity
gannon the scourge of hyrule castle who
torched the kingdom 100 years ago
and is now on the verge of breaking free
once again with princess zelda
desperately trying to restrain him
after starting the adventure there is
very little reason to return to the
shrine of resurrection
other than collecting one of the 900
corox seeds hidden across
hyrule that is until we boot up dlc pack
2
the champion's ballot little did we know
the entire room link was recovering in
doubles as a giant elevator
leading us deep down into another
ancient chica construction
a massive underground trial consisting
of cogs wheels and many more moving
parts which can be manipulated using the
sheikah slade
the similarities this place has to the
inside of the four divine beasts has led
some to call it the fifth divine beast
an understandable conclusion as it has
almost the exact same
rules and mechanics obtaining the map
first manipulating its mechanics
solve a few puzzles until you're finally
ready to face the boss and call it a day
it even has the same lazy enemy
placement in the form of a few guardian
robots and that's it
the only real difference is that instead
of one of ganon's blights the final
stage of the trial instead leads to a
sheikah monk
just like the ones we saw in the shrines
unlike the four divine beasts which were
corrupted and taken over by ganon's
malice this place seems to have been
untouched by his influence
also like the shrines so in that sense
it's kind of like a hybrid between a
shrine and a divine beast but unlike
these
this place seems to have served a
different purpose the divine beasts were
built to be operated by a pilot and
served as a support to subdue ganon the
shrines on the other hand were solely
built to test the hero tasked with
dealing the final bloat again and using
the sword of evil's bane i.e the master
sword
at first glance it seems like the final
trial served the latter
a test for the hero after all upon
defeating monk moscosia he states that
link has now proven himself to be a true
hero and the reward the master cycle
zero seems like it was made specifically
for him alone
but let's back up for a moment here we
actually already know that the fifth
divine beast
does indeed exist and it's not the final
trial itself but instead
as you probably have guessed the master
cycle itself muskosha does indeed point
this out right as you start the dlc
quest inside the shrine of resurrection
i now address the one who wishes to
master a divine beast
so yeah the bike is the fifth divine
beast not exactly on the same
scale as the other four but hey who are
we to judge
and when you really think about it the
master cycle zero is very fitting for
the hero to pilot
rather than a giant behemoth the goal of
the other four beasts as stated before
was purely to provide support while the
hero and princess attempted to seal
ganon away they were never designed to
outright defeat ganon on their own
as powerful as their giant lasers are
this isn't nearly enough to slay the
demon king
even with all 4 combined they were still
only able to inflict half his life bar
worth of damage and mind you
this calamity ganon wasn't even at its
full potential as masterworks points out
out of all parties involved the task of
the hero was by far the hardest and most
dangerous one
yes zelda did struggle to awaken her
powers at first
but that was mostly due to her own
insecurities and mental block but once
awakened we've seen what the wielder of
goddess hylia's power can do
she wouldn't even have to get all that
close to the demon king
instead she would have waited until he
was weak enough to a point that she can
send him into the void using a massive
surge of energy the hero on the other
hand
is the only one involved who would have
to make direct contact with ganon by
striking him with the master sword
in other words getting close enough to
be in sword's range
as such the master cycle zero would be a
fine addition to his arsenal to
accomplish his goal
as it grants him much greater speed and
mobility to close the distance and avoid
the demon king's attacks
not that this was hard in the actual
game but let's not talk about that that
was just lazy boss design
another reason why it's clear that the
master cycle zero was specifically
designed as a fifth divine beast to be
used
by the hero is that it's tied to the
sheikah slade this is one more thing
that makes the bike stand out from the
other beasts as it functions as a rune
inside the slate and can be summoned or
stored inside at any time
although we mostly saw zelda using the
slate 100 years ago
because of her interest in the sheik
attack it was never actually intended to
be used by her we can see this in one of
the cutscenes from 100 years ago where
she tries to use it on one of the
shrines and it doesn't respond to her
the slate was indeed designed to be used
by the hero as it is tied to the shrines
meant to test him
we also have to keep in mind that link
likely wasn't the first hero to face
ganon using the sheikah slate
we know of at least one hero that
preceded him in doing so
and this hero actually succeeded on his
first try since ganon wasn't aware of
the sheikah weaponry at that time this
makes for a strong argument that this
ancient hero
may have been utilizing the full
potential of the sheikah slate and thus
the master cycle zero
as well since the ancient chica who
built the technology were still alive at
this point in time and would have been
able to explain how it all works
an advantage which our modern day heroes
didn't have
so with all that said let's redirect our
attention to the final trial
since we already established that this
place isn't the fifth divine beast
what is it then the shape of the
facility itself has already sparked some
interesting ideas as the layout shares a
lot of similarities to that of a
combustion engine
the four cylindrical rooms protruding
out on the sides are just like that of
the cylinders of an engine
in turn the entire structure is
connected by spinning parts which all
come together in one central cog
and can be spun clockwise or
counterclockwise simulating
forward and reverse it even has a giant
fan another common thing found in an
engine
this has brought forth some pretty wild
speculation
like the idea that this facility is
actually inside the master cycle zero
and is then magically shrunken down by
moss kosha upon completing the trial
i do not believe this to be the case
though yes the trial is
connected to the master cycle but its
layout is probably just a clever
foreshadowing of the reward at the end
not only that but it's also based on the
assumption that the final trial was
designed for the hero
and the hero alone and the more i looked
into what this place really is
the more i realized that this is
probably not the case at all
let's start with the first piece of
evidence masterworks the final trial is
barely mentioned in the book but what
little it does have to say about it
is quite interesting the shrine of
resurrection this medical facility
contains an apparatus large enough to
fit a person and is designed to heal
wounds
underneath is a large trial used to
train the champions of the divine beasts
notice how it says champions as in
plural
the trial is described as a place where
they would train probably in preparation
for the confrontation with ganon
meaning it wasn't built just for the
hero but in fact for
all five champions and the closer we
look at the final trial
the more obvious this becomes the
facility is split into five different
sections
and not counting the elevator and the
room where the monk resides the four
cylindrical rooms on the sides and one
central chamber
the central room houses a guidance stone
meant to be activated by the sheikah
slate and the other four
are each designed around a specific
element fire
water air and electricity the same four
elements each of the pilots of the
divine beast possessed
in turn the door leading to moscow which
is locked with four giant bolts
each have a shika symbol on it
corresponding with the first letter of
each element
and then another bolt in the center with
a symbol representing the four divine
beasts on it this symbol is also found
all throughout the facility by the way
and even the one hit obliterator which
link is meant to wield at the start of
the dlc is shaped just like it this
symbol also perfectly illustrates the
connection between the five champions
the four divine beasts at the end of the
fork and then the hero at the center of
it all represented by the handle
so with all that in mind here's what i
think the facility was
originally intended to do upon entering
the facility the hero would use the
sheikah slate to gain control of the
central mechanism by manipulating the
interior he would then open up the path
to each of the four side rooms one by
one the pilots would then enter the room
corresponding to their element and solve
the puzzle
inside upon succeeding this would then
free up the terminal in each room which
could then be activated using the
sheikah slate releasing the bolts on the
door one by one
another interesting thing that happens
is that each time a bolt is released
a new set of guardian based enemies
spawns inside the central chamber
either these were meant to be defeated
by the hero alone or perhaps the
champions would collectively fight these
machines as a test of combat skill
we do find four weapons hidden in
treasure chests which are tied to the
race of the four pilots
and the hero would obviously be in
possession of the master sword upon
entering so it could be that defeating
the enemies in the central room was a
group
effort but i can't say that for sure
when all bolts are released and all
enemies defeated the hero would then
place the final part of the mechanism in
the center using magnesius
and presto the path to mascochia is
finally revealed and the final fight can
commence
i'm quite certain that the final duel
with the monk was meant to be fought by
the hero alone
a way for moscow to test his speed
agility and accuracy
in preparation to strike down the demon
king as the cherry on top he would then
be rewarded with his own divine beast
the master cycle zero which he could
then utilize during the final fight with
ganon
so you see not only was the final trial
a way for the hero to grow even stronger
and receive his own divine beast it was
also a group effort
a way to test and increase the synergy
and cooperation skills between the five
champions
combining their skills and intelligence
to solve one giant puzzle together and
possibly even fight enemies as a team
this also explains why link isn't
allowed to enter or is even made aware
of the final trial underneath the great
plateau
until he has tamed all four divine
beasts and received the essence of each
of the deceased
pilots when link receives one of these
skills he is essentially carrying a part
of that champion spirit with him
and since the final trial was designed
to be completed by five individuals link
wasn't allowed to enter until he
possessed the spirits of all four
champions plus his own so that they
would still be alongside him
even if only in spirit
god damn camera is never doing what i'm
hey there
it's me so i wanted to give a few
updates on the channel
and something for next week because some
things have changed
bear with me i'm terrible on camera and
i don't like doing this
at all so some of you may have caught
wind on the fact that i was working on a
big project
and some of you may have been wondering
where is it
some things have changed in my life
right now
i already posted it on discord so some
of those people are
already aware of it and the main gist of
it is that
i bought a house which is really cool
but it's also very stressful and there's
a lot of stuff involved a lot of
paperwork
a lot of stress not to mention i also
have to sell
this apartment to go with it so i'm both
selling a house and i'm buying a house
at the same time
as a result i will have to completely
reschedule this whole big project for
now because
it's just not doable it's it's too much
i might take some of the ideas from the
script
and make separate videos out of it
because i do feel like the script is all
already a bit
too convoluted right now i think i can
take some of it out or
simplify it and maybe turn it into a
separate little
smaller theory basically i also quickly
want to give a big thanks to brick colby
who's been kind enough to
review my script basically he's been
taking a look at it giving some feedback
and suggestions and although i'm not
going to be able to
utilize it as of right now it's going to
take a while but
you know once i do come back to this and
you know i start working on it refining
the script i mean
very helpful thank you to rick colby for
that
thank you man ah my eyes twitching
like the muscle muscles spasm in my eye
me and my fiancee we already kind of set
our goals of wanting to move this year
because
as nice as this place is this apartment
that we're living in right now it's
it's just too small it's too small for
two people
especially with the stuff that i'm doing
like recording
like even right now my fiance is locked
into
the bedroom
as you can see this is my desk sorry
about all the wires
never been able to clean those up
properly but yeah
this is where i work right now and
this is where my fiance works so
yeah we're pretty much back to back
so anytime i want to record something i
got to make sure that
she is either not working or doing
something else because
you know if she's doing the
this on the keyboard the microphone will
pick that up it is a very good
microphone but
it's not completely uh immune to
background sounds
so yeah because of this it's kind of
hard for me to just
sporadically record or produce something
uh be like oh i'm just gonna do a
midweek video all of a sudden
why not like it's just not doable
because of the footage i just showed you
a new house basically means that i
finally have a proper office to work
from you know i'll
be able to record anything i want
whenever i want
work on anything also i have a place to
retreat for a while for myself
so yeah that it's uh it is the the right
step to take for me in my life right now
that being said next week is the one
year anniversary of my channel
i mean yeah it's pretty crazy how far
we've gotten
in just a year's time so thank you all
so much for your support on that by the
way
just like i did with my 1k subscribers
special last year i want to get
you guys the the viewers involved again
so
um initially i thought maybe it's a fun
idea if you guys post your theories
either on discord or
somewhere in the comments or anything
like that and i would cover those and
put them all together in one video but
then i realized that's
not really the best way to go about it
because
theories require a lot of attention to
get the full potential out of them you
know you have to provide evidence you
have to
cover all the options that's just how
theories work you know
there's a reason why many zelda
theorists only use like
a top five or even a top three for for
those kinds of videos because
theories require a lot of time if i
choose to go that route we'd probably
only be able to cover about
10 of them max and that's already a
pretty long video that's probably going
to be like 30 minutes already
so if you want to participate i would
ask you to post your
unique idea about a zelda dungeon it can
be about draftable 2
or a dungeon for a future title like far
into the future whatever you want
um just something unique maybe something
that hasn't been done before
or with a new twist to it or something
like that
now before you start frantically typing
in your ideas into the comment section
below
i want to set some rules here first so
bear with me first i'd like to ask that
you keep it to one single idea you know
i know some of you might have lots of
ideas and that's awesome but
you know i gotta keep it organized for
myself and i want to
choose let's say 30 maybe 20 unique ones
from different people
next please do not put your idea in the
comment section
on this video or any video because it's
gonna get lost in between all the other
comments out there you know it's going
to get overlooked
it said i want to make a community post
so i can just have all the ideas
in one place so i can just easily skim
through the list and choose a couple of
them
lastly if your idea doesn't make it to
the list for whatever reason
please do not feel bad about it i will
do more videos like this in the future
like for another milestone don't take it
personally i have to make decisions here
i have to choose
a couple of ones that you know speak to
me personally
doesn't mean your idea is bad or i don't
like you
so keep an eye out for that community
post which will probably go up around
the same time as this video so
hopefully i'll see you there and that is
pretty much all i wanted to say
thank you for watching thank you to all
my patreons and members
i think we have a new member who joined
a couple of days ago
um thank you to maximilian smith
for joining you are awesome and that is
pretty much all for now
thank you for watching and until next
time